on va passer au débat d'aujourd'hui on
commence par le procès d'éc Dupont
moréti qui a pris fin hier première fois
qu'un garde des saau en exercice se
retrouvait devant la justice un an de
prison avec surcis a été requis contre
Éric Dupont moréti et la Cour de Justice
de la République rendra sa décision le
29 novembre d'abord audrait vous allez
nous expliquer ce qu'est concrètement
cette Cour de Justice de la République
bah c'est tout simplement la seule
instance compétente pour juger les
crimes ou délits commis par les membres
du gouvernement dans l'exercice de leur
fonction c'est une juridiction
d'exception créé en 1993 sous la
cohabitation mitéran Balad elle est
composée de 16 membres des magistrats
des parlementaires son président c'est
Dominique pote que vous allez voir à
l'image alors l'image est un peu sombre
mais c'est un peu la seule qu'on est il
est accompagné de trois magistrats de la
Cour de cassation élu pour 3 ans et de
12 parlementaires 6 sénateurs et si
députés c'est ces parlementaires vous
allez les voir à l'image vous av avoir
le temps de de regarder leur non euh
plus un groupe politique est important
plus il a de sièges dans cette cour leur
désignation se fait au scrutin
majoritaire à bulletin secret et au
niveau du Sénat bah ça a été revoté en
début octobre dernier parce qu'il y a eu
le renouvellement au scénat alors
comment ça se passe alors la Cour de
justice comment ça se passe et bien
toute personne française ou étrangère
peut saisir la Cour de Justice de la
République si elle s'estime laésée par
un crime ou un délit imputé à un membre
du gouvernement dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions souvenez-vous une plainte
avait été dép osé contre Édouard
Philippe pour sa gestion du covid-19
mais ça ne subit pas une commission de
requête fait le filtre pour éviter que
ces plaintes ne devienne une arme
politique contre l'action du
gouvernement si la plainte est recevable
des auditions commencent et c'est après
ces fameuses auditions qu'Édouard
Philippe n'avait pas été mis en examen
mais placé sous statut de témoins
assistés précisons enfin que le jugement
de la CGR doit se faire à la majorité
absolue et à bulletin secret depuis 1993
elle a prononcé un jugement à l'encontre
de 8 ministres de de secrétaire d'État
il y a eu des affaires très célèbres on
se souvient que la Cour de justice avait
relaxé Laurent fabus dans l'affaire du
sang contaminé et qu'elle avait juger
Christine Lagarde coupable de négligence
dans l'affaire Bernard tapis et cette
CGR elle est déccriée Audrey oui pour
ces longues procédures qui ne donnent en
général lieu à aucune condamnation mais
oui il faut un vote à l'unanimité et
puis beaucoup remettent en cause cette
justice d'exception et demandent à ce
que les membres de l'exécutif soit jugé
par des juridictions de droit commun
François Hollande avait même prévu de
supprimer euh la Cour de justice dans
son programme de 2012 Emmanuel Macron
l'avait appelé de ses vœux en 2018 mais
pour l'instant ça n'a donné aucune suite
ouais c'est une spécificité française
cette cour de justice Benjamin alors pas
vraiment parce qu'en réalité il faut
bien comprendre que le politique vous
l'avez évoqué mais est une cible si je
suis ministre et bien on peut vouloir
m'attaquer pour des raisons strictement
politiques mais en m'attaquant pour des
raisons strictement politiques et bien
on trouve le détour ensuite d'une
qualification pénale d'une qualification
et cetera et donc il faut malgré tout
qu'il y ait une forme d'exception vous
savez je vais vous donner un peu la
nostalgie mais sur la 3è République
cette course c'est le Sénat hein
historiquement les secondes chambres en
France comme d'ailleurs en
Grande-Bretagne la chambre des lordorde
également jusqu'à très récemment jusqu'à
2005 exercit justement cette fonction
évidemment aujourd'hui ça paraît
relativement anachronique d'avoir du
politique qui juge le politique
néanmoins il est clair que le ministre
n'est pas tout à fait injusticiable
comme les autres la réforme Hollande
était plutôt intelligente parce que
qu'est-ce qu'elle prévoyait elle
prévoyait de maintenir un filtre si
jamais je suis attaqué pour des raisons
strictement politiciennes il faut malgré
tout qu'il puisse y avoir un filtre et
là-dessus des politiques peuvent avoir
en effet une voix qui peut être une voix
intéressante à faire entendre dans le
filtre en revanche ensuite et bien sur
l'instruction qui déjà est dans la main
dans les mains de magistrat mais surtout
sur la prononciation de la peine le fait
d'avoir des magistrats professionnels
les mêmes que pour vous comme pour moi
et bien apparaît en effet quelque chose
d'assez légitime le problème aujourd'hui
de la CGR qui a quand même été créé en
réaction à l'affaire du sang contaminé
donc pour justement tenter de ramener un
peu vers le droit commun cette
juridiction d'exception le problème de
la CGR c'est pas tellement l'absence de
condamnation c'est surtout le niveau des
condamnations le niveau des peines qui
tout de même est infinétisim mal et
assez ridicule il y a d'autres problèmes
ensuite sur notamment les coaccusés et
cetera doné que vous pouvez pas vous
incriminer ça pose des problèmes global
globaux en matière de justice mais c'est
surtout cette prononciation des peines
et là évidemment si on avait des
magistrats professionnels comme pour
vous et moi ça désamorcerait quelques
critique sans sans enlever le
filtre oui alors c'est vrai que c'est
c'est une difficulté parce que je veux
dire un politique en exercice est
évidemment surexposé et la vraie
question est de savoir quelles sont les
intentions qui parfois peuvent l'amener
devant la Cour de Justice de la
République on voit en tout cas que la
plupart de ceux qui ont été condamnés
n'ont pas forcément en tout cas été par
la suite totalement interrompu ou arrêté
dans leur carrière personnelle donc
c'est pas une peine d'infamille d'une
certaine manière la la la Cour de
Justice de la République mais quand même
aujourd'hui à travers en tout cas
l'affaire qui dont on parle il y a quand
même un vrai sujet moi il y a un vrai
sujet si vous voulez au-delà de ce qu'on
pense de la CGR c'est la réalité c'est
qu'on est dans un pays où on a un garde
des saut aujourd'hui qui est poursuivi
euh et moi ce qui m'étonne le plus alors
quel que soi j'allais dire les ressorts
de l'affaire et la matérialité de
l'affaire sur laquelle moi je ne je n'ai
pas d'avis particulier c'est que
finalement ça passe totalement sous les
radars d'une certaine manière j'essaie
d'imaginer ce que eû été la poursuite
d'un garde des saau il y a 15 ans ou il
y a 20 ans dans notre vie politique à
mon avis le traitement eut été
certainement différent il y a une forme
j'allais dire presque de banalisation
d'une certaine manière de la
judiciarisation de la vie politique ça
ne fait plus scandale
l'opinion publique est assez amorphe et
même le traitement médiatique d'une
certaine façon est un traitement
médiatique qui se fait quasiment medzo V
moi c'est ce qui me frappe surtout si
vous voulez et ce qui me frappe aussi
c'est si vous voulez la comparaison avec
d'autres pays c'est que je ne suis pas
sûr que dans d'autres pays on on eu
autant d'indulgence que
l'indulgence que l'on a en France je
crois que c'est quand même il y a
là-dessus ça devrait nous interroger
quand même sur les j'allais dire sur les
sous éthique du fonctionnement de notre
de notre vie politique peut-être une
précision par rapport à la chronique
Éric Dupont Moretti est le premier
ministre à passer devant la CGR alors
qu'il est encore en train d'exercer son
mandat avant de de réagir par que ce que
dit Arne est très intéressant mais juste
pour pour rebondir sur ce que dit Audrey
est-ce que ça veut dire que il y a un
risque de jugement politique quand on a
un ministre en exercice qui est jugé par
ses opposants puisqu'il y a des
opposants dans les parlementaires est-ce
qu'il y a risque d'avoir un jugement
politique il y a des opposants il y a
également des membres de la majorité
alors sur quoi on parie en réalité on
parie sur ce qu'on appelle la
collégialité certes il y a des opposants
certes il y a des partisans vous avez
également trois magistrats et donc si je
suis un partisan que je commence à dire
vous savez Éric dupomoretti je le
connais c'est quelqu'un de merveilleux
il ne peut pas avoir fait le moindre
chose contraire à la loi c'est contre
son éthique si je suis un opposant et
que je dis le contraire la réalité c'est
que Maw va pas beaucoup peser dans la
délibération et donc ce faisant la
collégialité est réputé
représenter une garantie après vous
comprenez bien que cette garantie elle
n'est ni tout à fait compréhensible ni
absolue c'est le cas évidemment dans des
collèges dans des collèges de magistrats
mais encore plus ici donc évidemment que
ça pose question et ça pose un problème
pour les ministres parce que même s'il
était blanchi de main ben le doute va
subsister vous aurez toujours des gens
qui dirent qui vont se dire mais en fait
c'est le politique qui juge le politique
en fait il était coupable donc même pour
le ministre en réalité c'est quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui peut peser
problème la marque d'in famamille elle
demeure quand même même si jeis d'accord
avec Arnaud elle est moins forte que 10
et là on a perdu aujourd'hui quelque
chose vous savez dès le début en 2017
dès le début du premier quinquen
d'Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel Macron fait
quelque chose c'est qu'il remet en cause
ce qu'on appelait la jurisprudence Berga
baladure vous avez un ministre mis en
examen c'est pas une preuve de
culpabilité mais ça fait que et bien il
est contraint de démissionner c'est
arbitraire c'est peut-être idiot mais au
moins c'est une marque d le moment où il
dit écoutez là François Baayou sylvie
Goulard doivent quitter le gouvernement
parce que ils ne sont pas mis en examen
mais il y a une question à ce moment-là
ils casse cette règle-là ensuite il
maintient des ministres qui eux vont
être mis en examen avec tout son
caractère arbitraire la jurisprudence
bergova baladure permettez au moins
d'avoir une ligne claire vous êtes mis
en examen vous démissionnez vous n'êtes
pas mis en examen vous restez au
gouvernement aujourd'hui vous ne tenez
en réalité que parce que l'affaire n'est
pas trop médiatisée parce que et bien le
président continue à vous soutenir si
jamais vous avez un emballement
souvenez-vous de rugie le sègecheveux en
or et cetera là même s'il y a rien de
qualifi qui peut être qualifié
pénalement et bien vous devez quand
quand même démissionn et là il y a
beaucoup d'arbitrair beaucoup
d'injustice et c'est pas non plus très
bon pour le politique non c'est plus
compliqué avec Emmanuel Macron c'est
vrai que d'abord Emmanuel Macron il faut
jamais oublier qu'il a été élu dans un
contexte électoral très spécifique suite
au démélé
médiaticojudiciaire de son principal
concurrent enfin qui était François
Fillon à l'époque et c'est vrai que dans
un premier temps indéiablement il a
appliqué la jurisprudence bergovois
baladure notamment avec les par les
parlementaires les ministres modem il
était pas mis pas mis en examen non mais
enfin je dire mais la jurisprudence plus
loin que la J il est allé plus loin que
la jurisprudence oui il est allé plus
loin que la jurisprudence bgov baladure
c'est vrai mais enfin bon globalement
c'était l'esprit d'une certaine manière
c'est-à-dire un ministre soupçonné était
un ministre qui devait quitter le
gouvernement c'était ça globalement et
ensuite en effet il est il est revenu
sur cette jurisprudence et je suis
d'accord avec ce que dit Benjamin c'est
qu'en effet au moins cette jurisprudence
elle était importante parce que d'abord
j'allais dire elle préservait les
personnes mêmees quand elles étaient
attaquées ils avaient le temps et la
possibilité de se défendre sans qu'aucun
soupçon si vous voulez puisse peser sur
eux du fait qu'ils occupe une fonction
ministérielle donc de ce point de vue-là
elle avait un avantage évident cette
cette cette jurisprudence et puis
surtout le problème c'est que le fait
aujourd'hui de ne plus appliquer cette
jurisprudence entre guillemets vient
d'une certaine manière contredire
totalement sa volonté de moralisation de
la vie politique je rappelle que la
première loi qu'il fait voter c'est une
loi sur la moralisation la moralisation
de la vie politique donc ça contredit
tout à fait le message initial qui était
le sien et qui nous ramène quand même à
une époque où on était quand même
beaucoup moins vigilant vis-à-vis de ce
type de question qu'on l' devenu
finalement à partir des années 80 et des
années 90 un dernier mot Benjamin puis
queudre le rappelait dans sa chronique
François Hollande avait prévu de
supprimer la CGR pareil pour Emmanuel
Macron est-ce qu'il faut la supprimer il
faut pas supprimer encore une fois tout
élément de différenciation de la du
régime pénal des ministres pour moi et
aujourd'hui vous avez quand même pas une
unanimité mais quelque chose d'à peu
près consensuel il faut maintenir un
filtre le filtre qui pourrait être
composé comme l'actuel CJR qui fait que
et bien vous jugez si l'affaire est
strictement politique ou si elle ne
l'est pas quand même nécessaire prenez
par exemple la faire Buzin c'est
intéressant la faire Buzin est-ce que
prendre une mauvaise décision en matière
de gestion d'une épidémie ça du pénal ou
du politique vous pouvez être un
politique maladroit pouvez faire des
erreurs pouvez je tiis excusez-moi le le
terme mais merder la responsabilité elle
est politique elle s'exerce devant le
Parlement on peut discuter pas de motion
de censure qui passe depuis 62 la
responsabilité politique est émoussée
peut-être mais néanmoins la
responsabilité politique elle n'est pas
pénale le problème aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a une confusion entre
responsabilité politique et
responsabilité pénale lorsque je commets
un crime un délit de droit commun ma
responsabilité est évidemment pénale
lorsqu'en revanche je prends une
décision politique maladroite ma respons
abilité et politique confondre les deux
aujourd'hui la judiciarisation de la vie
politique n'est pas très très bonne
maintenir un filtre reste nécessaire on
va passer au second débat de ce club
puisqueaujourd'hui se tiennent les
deuxièmes rencontres de Saint-Denis
Emmanuel Macron qui a convié les chefs
de parti autour de la table mais tous ne
seront pas présent Olivier fort pour le
Parti socialiste Manuel bonpard pour les
insoumis Eric soti pour les républicains
ont décliné une attitude fustigée par
Emmanuel Macron je pense que utiliser le
contexte que nous vivons pour justifier
une une absence à une réunion de travail
sur des réformes
constitutionnelles est absolument
indigne de la part d'un dirigeant je
pense que c'est une faute politique
majeure de la part de ces dirigeants
c'est leur responsabilité mais aucun
prétexte ne le justifie et surtout pas
d'utiliser le contexte géopolitique
actuel et ce matin Éric cotier répond
dans une lettre ouverte je le cite vous
êtes le président de la République
française et vous devez en respecter les
institutions en démultipliant les
initiatives exter rieur au champ
institutionnel vous participez à les
affaiblir et à nourrir la crise de la
démocratie c'est ce que dit le patron
DLR à Emmanuel Macron qui a raison dans
cette affaire je suis surpris de la
virulence quand même du propos du
président de la République je ne sais
pas qui c'est qui l'a conseiller en
terme de de communication politique mais
je pense que finalement je dire comme il
le dit d'ailleurs c'est la
responsabilité des responsables
politiques d'accepter ou non
son invitation après sur le fond c'est
vrai que on voit que depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois il essaie de trouver une
porte de sortie à cette crise lente mais
corrosive de la démocratie je rappelle
que il a eu plusieurs initiatives le
Conseil national de la refondation
ensuite en effet ces rencontres de
Saint-Denis mais la difficulté c'est
qu'on ne voit pas véritablement ce qu'il
va en sortir ce qui peut en sortir
et ensuite ce qu'on comprend c'est que
de toute façon pour des raisons
politiques pour des raisons de rapport
de force
politique c'est ces rencontres sont
extrêmement j'allais dire piégeantes
pour les uns et pour les autres tant
pour le président de la République
d'ailleurs que pour
c'est c'est vis-à-vis des forces
politiques ce que je note quand même
c'est qu'il y a quand même quelques
forces politiques qui s'y rendent et
notamment l'une d'entre elles qui est
non la moindre c'est le rassemblement
national qui sera présent et qui d'une
certaine manière à travers cette
présence et à travers l'attitude deslr
continue à poursuivre son entreprise
j'allais dire de normalisation et de
banalisation je crois que c'est ça
peut-être l'élément le plus important de
cette rencontre ce jour et est-ce que du
coup il y a une faute ou pas de d'Éric
souti de ne pas y aller est-ce est-ce
que ça laisse le champ libre au
rassemblement national si vous voulez
Gérard larch il sera pour les
républicains parce que président du
Sénat mais il est deuxème personnage de
l'État président du Sénat et puis en
plus la majorité vous la connaissez
comme moi au Sénat comporte des gens qui
peuvent être proches éventuellement
d'Emmanuel Macron ou ne pas lui être
tout à fait fermé donc il a tout intérêt
à y aller heureusement qu'il y va pour
lui mais de l'autre côté je il y a trois
plan COM qui se répondent en réalité
vous avez un plan com du président de la
République on va être clair on en
reparlera peut-être tout à l'heure mais
le contenu de cette réforme il y a
aucune chance que à la fin on a une
révision constitutionnelle c'est
évidemment de la communication qui va
être question entre autes de
l'élargissement du
oui c'est ça alors pourquoi
élargissement du référendum bah ça fait
plaisir à LR au RN regardez moi je suis
président de la République je veux bien
faire un référendum sur l'immigration
regardez venez voter ma réforme je suis
ouvert et puis ça va dans le sens de
l'opinion idem pour le ricck hein le
ricck regardez la gauche le réclamé pour
exactement le gauche la gauche l'
réclamé pour les retraites merveilleux
regardez moi aussi je suis pour bref je
veux bien être tout ce que vous voulez
mesdames messieurs de l'opposition et
bien moi je vais dans votre sens donc
venez et si vous venez pas c'est de
votre faute vous voulez pas du RIC vous
voulez pas du référendum sur
l'immigration mais vraiment attendez
j'étais ouvert ça permet de montrer
comme le disait bien Arnaud qu'il bouge
or aujourd'hui il a des marches de
manœuvre limité ça permet de mettre en
porte à fau les oppositions c'est un
piège pour les oppositions quand vous
êtes Eric cotti quand vous êtes Manuel
bonpard vous avez tout intérêt à dire en
fait je ne suis pas dupe moi je suis la
vraie opposition surtout pour LR qui
aujourd'hui a un problème de
positionnement donc ça permet à ericotti
comme à ceux qui ne viendront pas de se
distinguer en disant nous ne sommes pas
dupes nous sommes la vraie opposition
nous ne nous rendrons pas à ce
rendez-vous pour le RN qui a are
problème qui est un problème de
crédibilisation et bien ça permet de
dire regardez nous nous sommes
l'opposition raisonnable le président de
la République veut nous parler de
géopolitique et de constitution on ne
peut pas ne pas être là alors que les
autres ne sont pas raisonnables plan com
génial pour Fabien Roussel ou marine
Tondelier nous sommes sur une ligne
différente aujourd'hui de celle de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon nous sommes une
opposition qui recherche une forme de
compromis ou en tout cas qui acceptant
également de nous rendre à une
convocation de président de la
République donc nous sommes également
responsable entendre la voix de la
gauche ceux qui viennent jouent la carte
de la responsabilité et la
différenciation vis-à-vis d'une are
opposition ceux qui ne viennent pas
jouent l'opposition frontale avec le
président ce qui le permet de vraiment
camper le camp de l'opposition et le
président essaie d'embobiner ses
oppositions et l'opinion tout le monde
fait de la com voilà tout le monde fait
de la comm tout le monde est gagnant on
va juste regarder dans des jeux de rôles
ce queécr parit vous fais réagir mais on
regarde just ce sondage aoxa pour Le
Figaro paru ce matin 61 % des Français
pensent que c'est une opération de com
ces rencontes de de Saint
oui mais ils ont pas de
T Benjamin Benjamin a parfaitement
décrit la situation on est véritablement
dans un théâtre où chacun finalement se
positionne par rapport aux autres et
joue une stratégie personnelle parce
qu'on sait très bien que en effet rien
ne sortira qui puisse être j'allais dire
validé par les faits et par le Parlement
de ces rencontres ça je crois que c'est
la réalité sauf surprise on n'est jamais
à l'abri d'une surprise en politique bon
enfin là ça me surprendrait beaucoup
contenu des rapports de force qui sont
ceux des rapports de force au Parlement
donc on est véritablement dans un dans
un dans un objet de avec un objet de
communication le problème c'est que trop
souvent aujourd'hui et avec raison nos
compatriotes considèrent que la
politique se réduit à de la
communication comme si à proportion que
les politiques ne pouvaient plus agir
était empêché pour des tas de raisons
que l'on n pas le temps de décrire sur
ce plateau finalement il surinvestissait
dans la communication on est au cœur
même de ce que constitue la crise
démocratique la crise tique c'est quoi
c'est pas seulement la crise de la
représentation c'est le fait que une
grande partie de l'opinion publique et
avec raison considère que l'action
politique n'a plus d'efficacité c'est ça
le vrai sujet aujourd'hui mais est-ce
que du du coup ça ça sera le dernier mot
est-ce que ces rencontres de Saint-Denis
c'est aussi la dévitalisation du
Parlement bah en grande partie en effet
parce que vous avez comment ça se
passerait dans une démocratie européenne
classique un régime parlementaire en
Espagne Italie Grande-Bretagne bref à
peu près partout sauf chez nous et ben
au lendemain des législatives on aurait
dit ok maintenant on va faire une
coalition et cette coalition va
s'engager sur un programme qui n'est pas
celui du président de la République mais
qui est un un programme que nous allons
négocier entre nous et ensuite on vote
les budgets et grosso modo ça marche ça
arrive partout ailleurs hein la la
période que l'on vit ici avec une
absence de majorité absolue nos voisins
connaissent ça depuis 1945 et c'est pas
fondamentalement un problème dès lors
que vous savez former des coalitions en
France nous n'avons pas cette culture là
il faut être pour ou contre le chef de
l'État et pour ou compte le programme
qu'il vous a proposé lorsqu'il a été élu
même sans majorité et donc ce faisant et
bien forcément vous av un chef de l'État
qui doit tenter de et bien passer
au-dessus du Parlement pour trouver
ensuite des subterfuges de com et
potentiellement des alliances texte par
texte ça c'est très particulier juste
sur un plan historique très rapidement
sur un plan historique ça a pas toujours
été vrai dans l'histoire politique
française ça aller depuis la 5e
République c'est la 5e République qui
est un élément de polarisation du débat
autour en effet de la personnalité du
président de la République allez c'est
vendredi vendredi on découvre notre
patrimoine vous le savez Samia de chir
et Pompeo copola nous emmè en Normandie
à Orbec où une ancienne carrière de
pierre abrite la dernière
champignonnière en cave du
Calvados c'est une culture cachée dans
les profondeurs d'une ancienne carrière
de pierre nous sommes dans la
champignonnière d'Orbec exploitée par
Olivier pérel et son épousez regardez là
vous en avez des gros venez voir le but
c'est tou cuueillir un champignon ferme
et fermé son produit phare le champignon
de Paris pousse dans l'obscurité il nî
de la moisissure produite par des sports
mélangés à du compost ce qui est blanc
en fait ça c'est du myelllium c'est la
moisissure une fois que ce mycélium donc
est bien développé on va rajouter une
couche de tourbe et euh au bout de 2
semaines à peu près le champignon va
apparaître il n'ajoute rien d'autre pas
d'engraé de produits phytosanitairees
pas d'arrosage ni de chauffage dans
cette ancienne carrière de pierre toutes
les conditions sont réunis pour que les
champignons poussent tout seul une
champignonnière industrielle c'est un
milieu maîtrisé on maîtrise la
température on maîtrise l'oxygénation on
maîtrise l'humidité bref ce champignon
il est encadré nous nous sommes dans un
milieu naturel à partir de ce moment-là
la la ventilation et l'humidité
l'oxygénation elle est faite par l'air
extérieure donc on ne maîtrise pas
c'estàd que quand il fait chaud on de
l'air chaud quand il fait froid on de
l'air froid un peu plus loin on trouve
le chitake une variété japonaise lui sa
particularité c'est qu'il va pousser sur
du bloc sur des blocs de bois alors
c'est du bois qui a été déchieté qui a
été reconditionné qu'on a ensemencé de
sport de chitque et qu'on a mis en
condition de pousse tout simplement si
les champignons poussent presque tout
seul le travail de cuillette lui est
quotidien il faut être présent toute
l'année 7 jours sur 7 le champignon
c'est travail de main d'œuvre c'est la
cueillette c'est le plus gros poste
quasiment de charge et qu'aujourd'hui et
bien la production a surtout été
délocalisé en
Pologne vous connaissez la problématique
des coups de la main d'œuvre ce qui a
fait que les champignonères Françaises
n'ont pas tenu la
concurrence elles ont fermé les unes
derrière les autres elles ont disparu
les unes derrière les autres la France
ne compte plus qu'une poignée de
champignonnière artisanale quand il
s'est lancé dans le métier il y a 8 ans
Olivier pérel ne connaissait presque que
rien au champignons il a appris sur le
tas alors là je vous présente notre
production de
plorotte le cuueille je sais qu'il va
venir hop il est venu tout seul parce
que lui je sais qu'il est prête à cuill
était prête à consommer alors là vous
avez un super spécimen très beau produit
sa fierté ce n'est pas seulement son
produit c'est aussi de maintenir une
activité dans ce lieu où l'on cultive le
champignon depuis 1930 et où les
habitants d'Orbec ont trouvé refuge
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est une question de sauvegarde c'est
une question de de de perpétuer je
dirais une histoire et qu'elle n'est pas
finie on va dire on est fier aussi parce
que quelque part on participe à la vie
d'un bassin de vie on participe je DIRIS
la vie d'un d'un village on est dans un
milieu rural où l'activité économique
n'est pas toujours évidente ça permet de
de garder une vie tout simplement si la
dernière champignonnière en kèf du
Calvados fait de la résistance c'est
surtout grâce à la vente directe 80 % de
la production s'écoule sur les marchés
de 6 à 15 € le kilo selon la
variété et voilà pour cette
champignonnière on regarde ce qu'elle
est une de nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux et Audrey ce sont les
intempérés qui font la Une oui la pluie
la pluie et encore la pluie dans le Nord
qui tente de penser ses plai après les
inondations la solidarité s'organise
pour sauver ce qui peut l'être rapporte
la voie du Nord les habitants de
Madeleine sous Montreuil ont formé une
chaîne hum humaine pardon pour
consolider une digue et tenter de
préserver les habitations des eaux à
l'Est à Chalon un mur anticru sera monté
aujourd'hui pour éviter justement les
inondation la pluie exaspérante
soulligne l'Union qui ne permet pas pour
l'instant de recharger les nappes
fréatiques rappelle le Courrier Picard
parce que ça prend du temps ce qui
n'empêche pas l'Est Républicain de voir
le verre à moitié plein après un été sec
les récoltes fourragères sont
exceptionnelles mais la vigilance reste
de mise car une nouvelle tempête est
arrivée sur notre territoire Federic
avec des rafales à plus de 130 kmh elle
a déjà fait des dégâts dans le puit d'Ô
nous rapporte la montagne regardez C
enage intérieure des éléments de toit de
façade ont été emportés à cler
monontferrand avant de tomber sur la
voirie sans faire bien heureusement de
victimes nos quotidiens reviennent sur
la décision de la Commission européenne
de prolonger l'autorisation du
glyphosate pour 10 ans et ça fait la Une
des Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace mais
qui dit autorisation ne veut pas dire
obligation ça veut dire que chaque pays
doit maintenant décider ce qu'il va
faire évidemment les Dernières Nouvelles
d'Alsace se demandent ce que va faire la
France la piste la plus probable c'est
qu'elle va continuer à encadrer
l'utilisation sans l'interdire car il
n'existe pour l'heure aucune solution
aussi efficace et surtout aussi peu cher
le télégraphe soulligne d'ailleurs que
la Bretagne a du mal à s'en passer et
puis je termine avec un peu de couleur
ça se passe à Montpellier c'est la 8e
édition du cœur de ville en lumière un
spectacle à découvrir jusqu'à demain
soir avec regarder des compositions
projetées sur les sites les plus
mémorables de la ville et notamment les
arceaux de montpol merci AUD merci
beaucoup la de la revue Politique et
parlementaires Arnaud le savant le
politique et le peuple l'enjeu du siècle
merci beaucoup Arnaud Benedetti merci et
merci Audrey on se retrouve lundi et on
vous souhaite un très bon
weekend